welcome back to 8701 so in this lecture
we talk about nuclear fission
we've already seen the process when we
discuss the empirical mass formula
um nuclear fission occurs in very heavy
nuclei as you can see in this plot here
fission processes on this part of the
spectrum
but what happens and what can happen
spontaneously is that the parent nuclei
just simply breaks up into daughter
nuclei
and maybe some additional neutrons um
one example is the decay
of uranium 238
one can also induce fission here is a
plot of the
nuclear potential with the coulomb wall
here
and you know for example you have this
nuclear
which sits here you know this could be
uranium 238
and you know you are able to bring it
above
this activation energy um
this again this can and some nuclei
occur spontaneously
in others it's being induced and then
you just break up the two
uh break up the nuclei into two daughter
particles
so if you for example start with a
neutron and you just bring it
close let's say you bring a neutron
close to
uranium 235 this forms uranium-236
and the fact that the neutron is being
absorbed excites then
this zero kinetic energy neutron excite
the daughter compound nucleus with an
excitation energy in this case of
6.5 mbv and because of that it then
quickly undergoes fission so you
basically add a thermal
or zero kinetic energy neutron and uh
when it's being absorbed it immediately
causes the fission process
the fission fragments and carry away
some energy um
in this example he has about 180 nav
and additional prompt neutrons and so
those additional problem neutrons
depending on the specific decay process
the number can be varying between zero
and six and for
uranium 235 the average number is 2.5
and then the fragments they might
undergo
additional decay process maybe better
decays eiffel decays
and when they do that they can also
release additional neutrons
so interesting now is to see whether or
not there can be a self-sustained
reaction a chain reaction and whether or
not this occurs depends on
the number of neutrons being emitted
so if the number of neutrons produced in
the n plus
first stage of the fission process is
greater than the number of nutrient
produced in the end stage of the fission
process
the process is either critical or
supercritical which means
it is able to because it produces more
neutrons and it needs to continue to
have efficient process
it will have or create a chain reaction
if the number is less than one
the process will die out and this is
exactly what's used in
nuclear fission reactors there's you
know
several types of reactors available
the example i want to discuss here very
briefly is the one of a thermal
reactor which uses uranium as fuel and
low energetic
low energy neutrons to establish the
chain reaction as we just discussed
and so this is a sketch here and the
sketch has
three different elements the first one
is the fuel element the fuel element can
be natural
naturally occurring uranium and then we
have a
moderator material and the purpose of
the moderated material
is to slow the neutrons down so if you
really start from
naturally occurring uranium you might
have to
find some sort of material material
which which
allows you to efficiently slow down the
neutrons which when they're
being emitted into the in the fission
process
and this could be so-called heavy water
where
um the the hydrogen in water is replaced
in parts at least with
deuterium but there's other examples for
this as well
and then you have those very important
retractable rods
let's see they're materials which have a
large cross-section to capture
neutrons and so what you can do with
them by mechanically
adding them or removing them from this
from this
environment is you can remove
additional neutrons so what you're
trying to do is
control this number k here
control whether or not there's enough
neutrons available
in order to sustain the chain reaction
and then
the excess energy is converted in heat
you can for example heat up water and
then just have a turbine run
in order to produce energy
you